Übung 10 Dehnung der
hüftflexoren starten Sie mit aufrechtem
Oberkörper auf dem Boden kniend und
stützen ihre Hände seitlich am Rumpf ab
stellen Sie nun ein Bein nach vorne auf
schieben Sie nun das Becken und den
Oberkörper nach vorne bis sie eine
Dehnung auf der Vorderseite ihres
knienden Beines spüren können achten Sie
dabei darauf dass das Knie des vorderen
Beines nicht über die Zehen
hinausgeschoben wird und das Becken
gerade gehalten wird halten Sie diese
Position für 5 Sekunden und kehren sie
danach wieder in die Ausgangsstellung
zurück wiederholen Sie diese Übung 10
bis 15 Mal auf einer Seite und wechseln
Sie dann das
Bein